I was born and raised in Big Stone Gap
morning beautiful I don't know why you
honking the horn I'm standing out here
blackest night I know you can see me
before I knew it was nineteen
seventy-eight now turned 40 I was the
old maid at this point you just gotta
take whatever you can get
he was out last night suit Tinsley come
on she's a catch okay Gary Cooper a big
stone gap you had sheriff suitors Jack
Mack lacks Ave Maria you know less about
men than you do about cosmetics my
favorite book on Chinese face reading no
no I've read the face of every man I've
ever known never been wrong you don't
need a book to learn what to do with me
this is an old toaster but when he plugs
it in your mama can't save me about
doing well when people die that's when
old sacred come out this is my father if
sure explains your nose me to marry can
you be my maid of honor darlin that's it
she married room strong and the two
shall be one Wow guard of mirth is
anybody at this wedding so
I saw my father in a dream and I have to
go find him I'm leaving I'm going to get
leave today videos I got a good job got
some money saved I think we should get
married don't want to just get married
tell me trying to kill me see what is
your heart contain give them everything
I have to this place I'm gonna see him
do so much it changes me tell me trying
to kill us anyway
I like being the town spinster it has
cachet yeah well you can't hug cachet
and this different person has touched in
kind of home ice is nice and I do this
week i'm a tease